[Music]
for years the saccone jolie family have
been documenting their life online
hello
welcome to the vlog
to almost 2 million loyal followers
but they've turned their backs on
youtube and now focus on mental health
and gender identity
i want to show the world that it's okay
to be who you really are
dad jonathan recently revealed he's
non-binary and their second child born a
boy is now a transgender girl
[Music]
choosing to change her name
people will say like oh you're forcing
it on her or she's too young to know
what's going on i'm like but that's
that's your lack of you know um
kind of exposure to to that environment
you don't have a trans child you are not
a trans person when she was telling me
how she used to have sleepless nights
because she saw a video about puberty
and thought like i don't am i gonna grow
facial hair am i gonna like
i'm gonna have babies right when i grow
up like i'm gonna be a mummy right i
don't know how to answer that question
because it's really sad and to see a
child just be questioned at all be like
i'm in the wrong body can can i change
please as jonathan uses his platform to
inform others
those within education are calling for
better support on gender issues new
research shows almost 80 percent of
secondary school teachers have students
who identify as trans or non-binary and
two-thirds say they'd like
government-approved lesson plans on the
subject
teachers aren't experts
in trans children and trans people and
that's really why we want the government
and the dfe to help us
setting those policies in particular you
know changing rooms toilets
sports in particular and single sex
schools
the department for education says it's
considering its next steps in supporting
schools with gender identity it comes
after the government said a ban on
so-called conversion therapy won't
include trans people what would you say
to those people
eight-year-old edie's response to this
conversion is simple
i would be um
sad
but um i would also
and
keep trying to convince you that i
wasn't a boy
charlotte lomas
[Music]